so time then for the press preview we're
taking a first look at sunday's front
pages and tonight
we'll analyze the headlines with the
times and sunday times columnist matthew
syed and the journalist and author
christina patterson looking lovely with
her flowers in the background
first of all though let's take a look at
some of the front pages starting with
the sunday express
leading with a pledge from the prime
minister to offer a coronavirus vaccine
to
every adult in the uk by the end of july
and that some mps fear his end of
lockdown plans are
too cautious well boris johnson's
vaccine promise is also on the front of
the sunday telegraph
raising hopes it says for summer
holidays
let's bring in the front of the observer
a leading scientist and government
advisor says there's no need for the
government to be ultra cautious
in lifting restrictions on outdoor
sports for children and small numbers of
adults
and the daily star on sunday says the
daughter of les dawson believes her
father is watching his grandson
from beyond the grave
and i'm joined tonight bye matthew syed
and christina patterson great to see you
both thanks for being with us
this saturday evening we need some good
news and uh there seems to be plenty of
it on the front pages certainly when it
comes to
monday's announcement by the prime
minister lots of anticipation of course
christina why don't we start with you
front page of the
telegraph it's also actually the front
page of the the sunday express as well
vaccine
for all adults by july as hope is raised
for holidays it could be a good summer
couldn't it
well i really hope so i really really
hope so i must say this is
very very good news and um even i who
have not been
particularly um supportive of the
government over the past year
have to acknowledge that the vaccine
program has been
a huge success i clearly the nhs has
played an enormous part in that but this
army of volunteers and people just
giving up their time and coordinating
this like a kind of
mass military operation has been really
fantastic
and after the the year we've had and
this winter has been
long and hard and difficult and even i
who i'm you know not exactly an outdoor
sporty kind of person i'm now
desperate to get out so i i that this is
really tremendously good news and
if if we do manage to have um the entire
adult population with at least one dose
of vaccine by july
that will be fantastic it doesn't mean
we can instantly
open the floodgates as the so-called
covert recovery group would like us to
do
but it does mean that we should be on
our way back to something much more like
normality which is wonderful
yeah absolutely uh matthew we'll all be
listening on monday
uh and we will hear no doubt many times
the word
cautious and caution uh interestingly on
the sunday express under its main
headline it says mp sphere boris
lockdown release is still too cautious i
mean do you think
there is an argument that perhaps the
prime minister is going to
overcompensate
this time as a result of mistakes that
have been made in the past
well it's certainly been a significant
lesson learned which is if you open up
too
soon the happiness and the the the joy
bordering on euphoria i think all of us
would feel if we could get out of
lockdown get out of our homes meet other
people get back to school
get the shops open get hospitality open
bars and restaurants all the things that
as social animals we crave you have to
go into reverse
and that undermines everything that you
hope to achieve by the early
reopening so it's not impossible there
will be
an over compensation but i do think it
will be fascinating to hear what the
prime minister has to say
uh tomorrow as christina said the the
vaccine news is
is excellent all adults by the end of
july will be
offered a jab that that super be very
interesting here what he has to say
about the extent the precise extent to
which that has cut down
uh severe illness and death and also i'd
love to hear
the most recent data on the extent to
which the vaccination
uh is uh preventing transmission of the
virus
um but but you know instinctively i'd
love to see everything open but i
i understand uh the prime minister's
caution
um i'll just stay with you matthew while
we look at the front page of the
observer because it's a
a story about sports um a passion of
yours ban on outside sport can end
top scientist urges johnson i mean
things like golf and tennis
and you can sort of understand can't you
how people want to get back out there
especially as the weather starts to
improve and actually the risk of playing
something like tennis and golf
pretty low this i think is
the significant thing for me outdoor
sport
the risk is remarkably low the data has
been clear on that almost from the start
and this scientist who's talked to the
observers talked about
groups of children being able to play
outdoor sport my son plays football he's
seven years old
it is such a wonderful thing to do when
you've been shut inside you're being
homeschooled
you're not seeing your friends it's not
just the physical activity it's the
sociability i mean young people are
developing their social
faculties at this age and i think that
would be a huge benefit to
not just to to to children in my
fortunate circumstance of middle class
people from tower blocks and that's
their only chance to get out
but you're right for adults too and i i
say that as you say i'm into sport
but i'm a big tennis enthusiast and you
can play completely safely on the other
side of the net from your opponent
you can mark the ball so that you don't
don't don't
both touch them um so i would love to
see uh
tennis and golf uh re introduced into
into society yeah um and let's just talk
about school's christina briefly
because uh one of the things obviously
we're going to hear about is the opening
of schools once again on march the 8th
um there has been some discussion about
what sort of reopening we can expect
what would you like to see do you want a
full opening of all schools
all pupils or do you think a staggered
approach would be better
well look you know i'm i'm not an
epidemiologist but if chris switzy
thinks that a staggered approach would
be better and
uh and head teachers seem to think that
a staggered approach would be better
then
i'm inclined to think that they know
more about it than i do and
i know that there is a lot of anxiety
about this so-called big bang approach
and
given as matthew said a moment ago
it would be so awful to undo all the
good that has been done during this time
by just
open the floodgates too quickly children
are desperate to get back to school
though let's not forget that a quarter
of primary school children have been
in school all this time but actually
unfortunately infection rates amongst
primary school children are currently
quite high they are higher than in
amongst children and young people they
are higher than
in any other section of the population
at the moment so we can't assume that
schools returning will
have zero risk there will be infections
and those infections will spread to
parents
and to grandparents and anyone else
children come into contact with on
school buses or trains or whatever and
so i'm afraid we will expect to see a
rise in infections
i hope it won't be too high but
personally i would much rather go for a
staggered cautious approach
yeah okay let's stay with the front page
of the observer
matthew and uh this story i mean very
depressing you know we've been talking
about the good news
that's hopefully coming in the next few
days the bad news of course
is uh unemployment and poverty
and this new research that shows
household poverty had soared
during the pandemic talk us through this
so this is a report that shows that the
number of households living in
destitution
which is a two-person household after
housing costs living on less than 100
pounds a week
has doubled during the course of the
pandemic this i think is going to be one
of the
long-term scourges economic and social
challenges
uh in the aftermath of this it's gonna
massively increase inequality in an
already unequal society
and we've seen how the virus itself
has typically uh brought great
uh distress illness to poor and more
vulnerable people in our society and i
think one of the
most important things for the government
and actually this is going to last for a
very long time
labour party too setting out credible
social and economic policies to
alleviate what is going to be
a huge legacy uh of this pandemic
yeah christine let's get a final thought
on on this from you before the break
well it's tragic it's it's nothing less
than tragic uh
covet is a health care disaster and for
people who've lost loved ones it has
been a tragedy but
it's also a tragedy to lose a job if you
can no longer
afford to support your family to go from
kind of average wage you know around 26
000 pounds a year to 100 pounds a week
for two people that is a terrible drop
and our benefits are extremely low by
western european international standards
and
i i think we've had this rise in
universal credit but it's been made
clear that
that is temporary and i think it should
be permanent i think that's a real
mistake of rishi sunax particularly if
he really does want to go for rather
boris johnson's who i presume
ultimately made the decision if we
really do want to go for levelling up
then
keeping people in that kind of level of
grinding poverty really isn't going to
cut it
i think this is the economic shadow and
legacy of covert is going to be enormous
and that's the test of us as a nation
what we do
afterwards and so far i have to say the
signs aren't looking great
yeah we may get more of an idea of
course in in the budget next month okay
for now
we'll leave it there christina and
matthew thank you coming up prince
charles's 100 mile trip
to visit the duke of edinburgh in
hospital don't go away
everything about admin everything we do
is about stories and characters
and uh in this project we wanted to use
those those skills to help uh
raise awareness in young people of some
of those common issues that can lead to
like more serious mental health problems
and in a way
that hopefully entertains and informs
rather than
rather than just lectures um issues like
independence loneliness perfection
perfectionism competitiveness um
negative social media use
yeah we we really just wanted to do what
admin does
and hopefully make something that that
uh
entertains people but also helps them a
little
i think certainly before the pandemic
there's quite a lot of
quite scary statistics about um sort of
young people's mental health
and i think that that age between 17 and
24 where
you you might be leaving home or going
to university
and those sort of big changes in your
life are happening
and that's when that's when those things
will start to manifest and
and what we want to do is sort of catch
people early if you like
so before it uh develops into quite big
things like depression
and anxiety deal with things a little
bit earlier when it's
um when it's more things like
perfectionism
and stuff like that and that's that's
when we hope we can kind of get in there
with our films and characters do you
think you have the energy to match
donald trump
i have more energy than all of them
while i may be the first woman in this
office
i will not be the last i'm cordelia
lynch and i'm skye's u.s correspondent
based in washington
i've witnessed deep loss in america deep
division and deep bravery how you doing
sir
everyone here is being intubated and the
chance of survival
is very slow there are parts of this
city that look apocalyptic
they are a symbol of deep anger
we're about an hour outside of the
capital and you can see
a young man's body just there once y'all
leave
they kill you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview uh still with me matthew side
and christina patterson uh matthew
let's uh get cracking uh front page of
the sunday telegraph uh
talk to me about this tax relief for
heavy industry to tackle
the north-south divide well we talked
didn't we in the in the last half about
the importance for support
for all of us as citizens the other big
battering that has taken place during
the pandemic is
those businesses that have struggled
because
of the virus and one of the i think very
sensible proposals is
tax relief for manufacturing industries
this will obviously help those
industries but also
as the government is saying level up the
the north south divide i mean all of
these policies do sound good i mean
we need support for the high street too
i live in south west london richmond and
so many shops are boarded up and the
decimation of the high street i think is
not just about the high street but
the social cohesion of communities
but as i say all of these policies which
cost money sound terrific but one also
has to keep
an eye on the the debt which is getting
higher
and higher and therefore debt interest
that we will have to pay gets higher
and the people have to pay it back will
be future generations
so in seeking i think completely
legitimately to equalize
uh society today we don't want to build
in intergenerational
problems and of course when there is a
very very big debt there's always a risk
of trying to inflate our way
out of it at the moment there's no sign
of inflation retail price has been very
low but with this quantitative easing
it's massively inflating asset prices
which is also leading
to higher inequality in the here and now
so i think it's very easy but perhaps a
bit glib to keep supporting everything
that the government is doing to support
industry business and so on but at the
end of the day
these decisions have consequences which
will be
felt in the long term what are your
thoughts on this christina
i think it it's kind of strange feeling
we
we know that the so-called red wall are
very very central to boris johnson and
rishi sunak's thinking because
those were the former labor voters who
in boris johnson's words uh
lent their vote to the tories and they
seem to rule the world at least in terms
of
uh what the government thinks um you
know wants to keep
what they want to keep their votes
basically i'm all for
this policy if it has a significant
effect
on employment but i do think there's
been a lot of talk
kind of about throwing money at the
infrastructure of the red wall
and i'm not sure the infrastructure is
the thing we really need at the moment i
mean clearly if
if the if this will make a significant
difference to
industries in manufacturing and
industries in the north which many of
which have been uh
severely damaged by brexit it has to be
said ironically enough
but if it does help then then great but
uh you know all of this has to be
targeted and to go back to matthew's
point about
um caution and debt yes of course
we need to be careful on that front
although i think this is a wartime
situation essentially i mean it's
a scale on the scale of a war and i
think
well in fact labor has uh argued that
one of the reasons we were so ill
prepared for this pandemic was because
of 10 years of austerity and
cutting for example nhs capacity back to
the bone
so i think we need a kind of just a much
more solid
healthy society so we can weather uh you
know kind of catastrophic events like
this in the future yeah
okay uh let's just finish uh with uh the
royal stories a number of royal stories
matthew going around
at the moment busy time for royal
correspondence
uh front page of most of the papers
showing that picture of prince charles
he
he popped in to see his father in
hospital
yes and um there's a lot of speculation
about
uh the facial expression of prince
charles and what it means i i wouldn't
wish to speculate on i mean obviously i
wish
his father or all the best in the world
the other royal story of course
is harry and megan i have to say i'm a
great fan of of of
of the royal family but um i'm not quite
as
as as fascinated uh in the details of
harry and megan as i know a lot of other
people are but i
of course wish uh the the duke of
edinburgh well
yeah of course we all do uh indeed and
christina very quickly a new uh a new
baby name
august it's quite interesting name isn't
it yes well uh august strindberg
uh springs to mind for those of us who
are both literary and scandinavian in
origin
so an excellent choice as far as i'm
concerned and very nice that they've
chosen to call
uh to give him the middle name philip
that's a very nice touch and i'm sure
that
prince philip will be will be very
touched by that so
very sweet to see as well the photograph
this tiny shrimp of a baby
uh who is you know i don't know if he
was early or not but premature or not
but
the contrast between a 99 year old
prince phillip and this tiny baby is
also very touching generationally so
wish them the very very best